on your next circle I want you to draw
another pair of equal chords another
pair of equal chords draw some different
ones and maybe draw them
let me draw them like this overlapping
something that looks interesting so I'm
gonna draw something that looks like
this
that's you okay so if I again have equal
chords like so okay what can I say about
their relationship to the center because
that's going to be you can see ii i've
put that word in there so
something-something are whatever from
the center if you have a look if you
have a look you can see from the center
if i measure the distance to these
chords if I measure the distance like so
I have to put a right angle let me say
that again if I measure the distance
from a point like the center to a whine
or interval like this chord I have to
measure the perpendicular distance would
anyone like to suggest to me why like
why can't I draw a line off over here or
there hmm I'll give you two reasons
number one it's the shortest distance
right if you want to get quickly from
the point to the line
then I'm going perpendicular just like
crossing a road going perpendicular the
quickest way okay but why do we want the
shortest distance like there's no reason
to necessarily morally say that's the
right one
we need a consistent way to describe
this distance because if I said you can
go anywhere along this line then here
you get a different length and and here
you get an even longer length and on and
on and on so I need something we can all
agree we can be consistent on so we just
say the shortest distance which is
perpendicular okay so I've got this guy
I'm going to measure the distance to the
other chord as well like so okay so you
have these two distances if you've done
the same thing as I have you've got two
chords the chords are equal in length so
let's call this P and Q again and our s
if P Q equals our s then let's give
these guys names let's call them m and
end what can I say about om that
distance to the court and om that
distance for the call what do they look
like
they sure look like they're the same
don't they
okay now how would you prove that's the
case again we're not going to go write
out the whole thing but think about what
we did over here
and how it could apply over there what
would you say the more colors you have
the easier you can do these kinds of
things if we put these constructions
back in from before the radii right so
here there's one pair of radii that
creates a triangle and here's another
one
it creates the other triangle right he
had the same congruent triangles as
before for the same reasons okay but
remember like what is congruent mean if
you had to someone had never heard the
word congruent and you wanted to give
them a synonym or a phrase that met the
same Congre what would you say what
would be your definition any suggestions
we've been using the word convert for a
long time we have a symbol for and we
know how to prove it if you had to if
the word Coghlan was struck out from the
English language
what code could we use to replace it
equal in size and shape would be perfect
right in every way these two things and
that's why they're congruent sign looks
so much like an equal sign right in fact
it's like an equal sign like a souped up
equal sign they're really really equal
everything is the same another word you
could maybe use is identical okay if
these two triangles really are identical
then these things here are the
perpendicular heights of those triangles
do you agree well if everything is the
same then these two are also the same
okay so I can say if the chords are
equal if P Q equals R s then I can say
the distances to the chords are also
equal okay
no that's the perpendicular distance
it's the shortest distance so how would
I say this this is properly to sorry you
really are gonna have to squeeze this in
it's not the same way equal chords equal
chords are
what's one word that means they are the
same distance away when we say when we
say triangles have all the same angles
we say they are it's one word it's a
long word we say they're Equis now yeah
so when we're comparing these two right
we would say these guys are equiangular
even if they're not equilateral right by
the way lateral means sides angular
means angles so these guys here are
equidistant because they're the same
distance from the center so that's
probably too eq you are I'll write it
for you
equi distant same distance okay okay now
I've held your head for these first two
properties I'm going to draw property
three obviously you don't know what it
is but I'm going to draw it I'm going to
then ask you to try and prove it like
use some logic like we've been doing
here and then see what wording would fit
into property three that matches this
diagram okay
so draw me a chord any chord may be
something like say this draw in the
center let's call this oh let's call
this P and Q this property and just make
sure I get the right one yeah that's
that's gonna be sneaky we'll do our best
okay I'm going to draw a line here and
I'm going to say that this is in the
middle okay if it's in the middle I'm
suggesting that it's at right angles
this is the picture that goes with
property three and this goes both ways
you know Pythagoras how if you know that
something is right-angled you can say a
squared plus B squared equals C squared
Pythagoras is lovely because it's
converse is true if you know that a
squared plus B squared equals
squared you can then conclude that the
triangle is right-angled so this
property it also goes in Reverse it's
converse is true you can go from right
angled to the theorem or you can go from
the theorem to the right angle okay this
one is also true if you've got this to
let these two links be the same then
you'll have this right angle or if you
have this right angle you'll get these
two legs be the same so the one property
captures both of those ideas all at once
I want you to see can you prove that
that must be the case if you've got that
bisecting happening you get a right
angle or vice versa and then can you
come up with a wording for it that fits
into property three okay I'll give you
guys a couple minutes to have a plane
well I join your circles okay would you
like me to show you I saw most people
have the right constructions if all else
fails in a circular geometry question
draw some radii okay because radios are
always equal so you'll find something
okay so I'm going to join up okay and OQ
let's do that so like I mentioned before
I can prove this in both directions so
watch me prove it in this direction if I
do not know if I do not know that
there's a right angle there but I do
know that p.m. equals M cube because
it's the bisector watch I know that
these two are the same because that is
the set up for the question I know that
they're things I just constructed OPP
and OQ are also the same because because
radii so that's good
and then lastly om see this length in
here it is a length that is in both of
these triangles the top one and the
bottom one so I would say om is common
now once you've got three sides it's the
same congruence proof you've seen before
it comes up quite a lot so these two
triangles are congruent that means all
of their corresponding angles are the
same but this angle and this angle
happen to correspond well if they're the
same angle but they're both on a
straight line then they both clearly
have to be 90 degrees do do you agree so
that's why I can say all right that's my
reasoning okay if on the other hand I
turn the tables and I say actually I
don't know that they are equal to each
other those legs but I do know this is a
right angle I'm just gonna have a
slightly different congruence proof
while congruence proof will I have so
RHS is the very uncommon Lee used one
but you have to use IHS because this
side and this side they do not include
this angle right you you need this angle
in here to use SAS does that make sense
so you've got right angle you've got the
hypotenuse you got a shorter side
congruence again which means that these
guys are corresponding links you're done
okay so there are more than one way to
say these but here's the way that I
would say property three V and we used
to easily this is an adjective but I'm
gonna use it as a noun the perpendicular
the perpendicular so that's a line that
is perpendicular to something else the
perpendicular from the center to a chord
bisects the chord it chops it in half
does that make sense I'll say it again
the perpendicular from the center to a
chord bisects the chord how would I say
this in Reverse if I didn't know his
perpendicular I would probably say the
bisector from the center to record is
perpendicular to the court it's the same
property but said in Reverse it's it's
the converse okay